i like to feel that there can be great
beauty in medical art
a beauty that really goes hand in hand
with science
as we explore the infinite inner spaces
of the human body
here we move deeper through the
spectacular caverns of the heart
and we feel like explorers in this
fantastic anatomical world
as the artist i like to become
completely involved in the visual
presentation
and my objective is to help the observer
become just as involved personally
artistically scientifically
here are some animated examples from a
film
now we have the chance to observe heart
function in a large variety of ways
the value of animation as an art form
is that it's a controlled medium
we can show specific action in time and
space
and we can have the advantage of being
able to expand or condense this time
in order to get the information across
there's a great value
and a lot of satisfaction
in being able to adjust our concept
frame by frame
as one would with brush strokes on a
painting
ever since man lived in caves there were
artists concerned with depicting
scientific truths
now these lascal cave painters felt that
the success of the hunt
depended on their ability to portray
their animal prey
as realistically as possible
there are some australian aborigines
that use an x-ray approach
they get involved with the total animal
including the internal organs
back in medieval times
these were almost as primitive in that
concept
but they did represent the technology of
the age
then came the great leonardo da vinci
painter sculptor architect engineer and
scientist
his anatomical art was probably his
greatest contribution in the scientific
field
this microscopic anatomy was done by the
dutchman jan swamidam
100 years before the invention of the
microscope
now the works of albert dura
were not scientific in the literal sense
but they reflect tremendous curiosity
for exact detail
even to the sore spots of his own body
here's the famous primavera by
botticelli
what infinite pains the artist took to
paint these flowers in perfect botanical
accuracy
during the 18th and 19th centuries
the artist scientists portrayed more
accurately than ever the anatomical
discoveries of their day
now we're back in our time
the eye for example can take on a new
look
and today i think we can
stimulate the viewer and create more
visual excitement than ever
we can explore the middle ear in terms
of its own ethereal space
its intricate forms its practical
sculptural beauty
sometimes information has to be
explained in an exaggerated manner
because it's too compact
to visualize in its normal state
or
sometimes it has to be portrayed in
non-realistic colors
so that we can reveal its inner
structure more clearly
at other times we have the opportunity
to take an artistic journey on film
using the vehicle of artwork and camera
mechanics
here
as we move through the lung structure
we can see its beauty in a normal state
all we can feel the chaos of it
in an abnormal state
by man's abuse of his own lungs to the
point of destruction
what might look like apparent chaos in
the area of head and neck anatomy
became for me an organized graphic
adventure
as for the variety of realism in the
oral cavity and its related structures
this makes its own demands on the
artists
what i found unique about walt disney
was his genius to convey nature's drama
in its many forms
in this case we were designing for
school children and the purpose was to
create an inner world of wonder
away from the anatomical look
as they watched the development of the
human fetus
in the film called fantastic voyage
tens of millions of people were exposed
for the first time
to the unbelievable wonders of their own
body
within the demands of the storyline
the big challenge for us
was to make the anatomy as authentic as
possible
here's another fantastic voyage
slicing through the human brain using
motion photography
in this sales piece
my goal was to make the presentation as
beautiful as it is informative
today in the field of medical
communication
i feel very strongly
that the concept of informative beauty
is a goal worth striving for
you